Laurent Berger le secrétaire général de
la CFDT et l'invité de preuve par 3
bonsoirir et merci d'être avec nous à un
moment d'ailleurs où le débat sur l'âge
de départ à la retraite est relancé
alors on est passé de 60 à 62 et demain
64 ans et plus en tous les cas le
ministre du Travail prévient s'il faut
allonger la durée de cotisation et bien
nous le ferons et vous réagirez dans un
instant bien sûr au propos de François
repsamen mais il y a tant de sujet sur
la table bien sûr la loi Macron le
climat social le chômage Jean-Philippe
chognot de l'Agence France Presse notre
partenaire pour preuve par 3 et
perinarna de Public Sénat nous
rejoindrons tour à tour Laurent Berger
d'abord donc le dossier des retraites
rouvert notamment par la Cour des
comptes pour qui la faillite des régimes
complémentaires et bien c'est pour tout
de suite de son côté le Conseil
d'orientation des retraites voit un
horizon moins sombre pour le régime
général mais il faut dire quand même à
partir d'hypothèses économiques plutôt
optimiste et le ministre du Travail donc
affirme que s'il faut allonger la durée
de cotisation et bien on le fera que lui
répondez-vous est-ce qu'il dit
l'évidence non mais je je j'avoue jeux
pas bien comprendre ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui sur les retraites là on a
une réforme en 2013 ce que dit la Cour
des comptes c'est sur les les les
régimes complémentaires il y a rien de
nouveau sous le soleil d'ailleurs la
Cour des comptes n'a pas vocation
elle-même à ouvrir le dossier elle dit
qu'il y a un régime qui est en
difficulté financière tout le monde le
sait la preuve on va renégocier avec les
organisations syndicales et patronnal à
partir de de de mars prochain pour
regarder comment on fait vous comprenez
pas ce qui se passe est-ce que vous
comprenez le ministre du trava le
rapport du corps il est il dit que la
réforme de 2013 a eu des effets
bénéfiques il a eu des effets bénéfiques
en terme d'équilibre financier à horizon
2020 certes avec des objectifs
économiques ambitieux mais en même temps
si on était pas dans un diront certains
oui mais mais ceci étant il montre que
il y a eu une des progrès sur
l'équilibre financier donc on va pas
rajouter de la réforme à la réforme donc
l'horizon 63 64 comme le disent les uns
ou les autres c'est c'est absolument pas
sur la table c'est pas sur la table et
alors quand le ministre dit même dit
lui-même qu'il sera prêt il serait prêt
à allonger la durée de cotisation s'il
le fallait que que lui répondez-vous non
mais je je lui réponds que c'est pas
d'actualité que nous venons de vivre une
réforme des retraites en 2013 qui a fait
bouger un certain nombre de curseurs y
compris sur la durée de cotisation et
qui a aussi prévu des mesures de justice
qui doivent rentrer en application
notamment la prise en charge de toutes
les périodes d'apprentissage pour
calculer la retraite et aussi la
pénibilité un vrai beau sujet donc
mettons cetteéplace cette réforme en
œuvre et pour l'instant il y a pas de
réforme supplémentaire à faire sur les r
d'accord mais pourtant l'allongement de
la durée de cotisation c'est bien encore
un levier que l'on trouve dans la loi
hos monsieur Berg c'est une possibilité
qui est offerte par la loi on pas le
droit d' parleris mais mais on l' on l'a
envisagé jusque une augmentation de la
durée de cotisation euh dans la loi hos
mais en en contrepartie il y a eu aussi
des mesures de justice notamment les
questions de pénibilité de d'avantages
familiaux concernant davantage les
femmes de prise en charge des PER
d'apprentissage pour les apprentis donc
la la réforme se met en place je crois
qu'il faut arrêter dans notre pays à
chaque fois que nous réformons à chaque
fois que nous mettons en place une
réforme nécessaire mais longue à se
mettre en place qui que quelques mois
après on l'a eu sur l'assurance chômage
cette situationl on l' sur le PACT de
responsabilité quelques mois après on
dit bah attendez ça va pas assez vite ou
peut-être qu'à l'horizon sera plus
compliqué il faut refaire une réforme
non installons la réforme des retraites
prévu en 2013 et il sera bien temps dans
les années à venir de regarder comment
on peut faire si jamais il y avait
d'autres problès donc pour vous la
réforme de 2013 ne doit pas bouger
pendant combien d'années alors pendant 2
3 ansbi tempendez PRV il a des
rendez-vous prévus nous sommes en
décembre 2014 ça fait 1 an 1 an que
cette réforme elle a été votée donc il
est trop tôt pour évidemment repartir
sur une idée de réforme pour la CVT
c'est non mais par contre sur la c'est
non si si demain le gouvernement mais je
ne crois pas que ce soit le cas parce
que vous citez pas Madame Touren qui a
dit qu'il y avait pas de il y avait pas
de calendrier en terme de réforme et si
ça si ça devait être le cas c'est non
pour la CVT nous avons d'autres choses à
traiter actuellement bien donc vous
allez le dire exactement à votre
Ministre un peu de tutelle j'ai envie de
dire le ministre du Travail il a pas
bien compris alors la situation je lui
dirais sil me pose la question mais je
pense que là avec votre émission il a
compris il a compris que c'était non de
la part de la CFDT pourtant vous avez
cité la Cour des comptes il évoque une
nouvelle borne d'âge 64 ans là aussi
quand on regarde tout ce qui se passe
dans les pays européens on a
l'impression qu'on n'y coupera pas et
par exemple lu MP Xavier Bertrand lui il
parle de de de faillite il parle de la
faillite ses deains et lui il parle d'un
âge de départ 65 ans oui mais vous savez
ça c'est l'espèce de totem des uns et
des autres qui va dire 65 ans 64 ans et
cetera faut distinguer deux sujets qui
sont sur la table je pense qu'il faut
parler à l'intelligence des gens et il y
a deux sujet sur la table il y a le
rapport de la Cour des comptes qui parle
du régime général je viens de vous
répondre il y a la réforme
pas de la Cour des comptes le rapport du
corps qui parle du régime général je
viens de vous répondre que la réforme de
2013 elle se met en place et d'ailleurs
le rapport du corps dit queelle elle
produit des effetsou par y a une
augmentation de cotisation mais là c'est
fini on do plus continuer à augmenter
les cotisations on va pas baisser les
pension donc la seule solution
éventuellement c'est de travailler plus
il en est pas question pour l'instant
puisque la réforme de 2013 a déjà prévu
un allongement de la durée de cotisation
qui n'est pas totalement en vigueur donc
laissons les choses rentrer en vigueur
et puis deuxième sujet c'est ce sont les
retraites complémentaires là la Cour des
comptes dit que il y a un syè un régime
financier qui est qui est en difficulté
et donc nous allons discuter en mars pas
sous la contrainte de la Cour des
comptes simplement pour assurer des
retraites complémentaires à l'ensemble
des salariés cadre ou non cadre ça sera
ça notre horizon nous ferons des
propositions en son temps mais nous
n'allons pas nous laisser dicter le
calendrier par la Cour des comptes
d'accord ni les solutions l'allongement
de la durée de travail comme dit la Cour
des comptes pour sauement laée de
travail complémenté travil concernerait
que le régime complémentaire c'est pas
le bon angle l'allongement de la durée
de travail qui a été prévu par la loi
elle doit être en 2013 elle doit être
fait pour par le régime général pas sous
l'angle le petit bout de la languette
même si c'est important du régime
complémentaire voilà ce que nous allons
dire d'accord bon voilà votre réponse au
ministre du Travail en tous les cas elle
est clair et nette et c'est vrai qu'il y
a eu plusieurs sons de cloche au sein du
gouvernement hein sur l'approche du
dossier sachant que c'est pour vous à la
cfdta un sujet très important Laurent
Berger puisque vous avez négocié le
compte pénibilité hein c'est-à-dire un
départ des avantages et un départ
anticipé par exemple pour les salariés
qui sont exposés à des conditions de
travail difficiles mais on a
l'impression quand même que c'est une
immense complexité là qui s'ouvre devant
les négociateurs vous en faites partie
c'est même cfcen puisque selon un
chiffre officiel quatre salariés sur 10
sont concernés alors comment est-ce
qu'on va faire pour distribuer des
avantages à presque la moitié des
salariés français puisque vous vous BZ
les chiffres je vais le faire aussi
quatre salariés sur 10 sont concernés
par des situations de travail pénibles
mais 2/ 10 seront concernés à peu près
selon les études par le compte
pénibilité hein donc qui qui prévoit une
réparation et puis deuxième chiffre si
vous permettez la différence d'espérance
de vie entre un cadre et un ouvrier qui
subit des situations pénibles au travail
c'est de 7 ans 10 % à peu près de
l'espérance de vie un peu moins mais de
l'espérance de vie de des individus dans
notre pays ça c'est pour dire que cette
mesure c'est d'abord une mesure de
justice sociale des gens des gens des
personnes qui tous les jours parce
qu'ils ont travail pénible savent que
leur espérance de vie ou leur espérance
de vie en bonne santé sera moindre du
fait de ces travaux pénibles et donc ce
que nous avons voulu à travers ce compte
pénibilité c'est d'abord que la
prévention soit à l'œuvre et qu'on
puisse mesurer cette pénibilité pour la
diminuer si possible et pour ceux pour
lesquels ce n'est pas possible de faire
en sorte qu'il y ait une réparation qui
est la contrepartie à l'allongement de
la durée de cotisation pour les autres
cette réparation c'est du départ
anticipé ou c'est de la formation
pendant la carrière question question
est que c'est compliqué la oui
apparemment c'est compliqué même même
encore le ministre du Travail je vais
encore le citer François repsamen il a
l'air de de souscrire à l'idée que c'est
quand même très compliqué puisque il a
engagé dans une espèce de rétropéd sa
vous savez sur la pénibilité j'ai pas
envie de parler ni au ministre du
Travail ni à Monsieur Gata j'ai envie de
parler aux gens qui vont en bénéficier
pour leur dire voilà vous voyez vous
vivez des situations de travail pénibles
nous les reconnaissons les 10 critères
de pénibilité vous savez qui les a fixé
c'est les partenaires sociaux syndicat
et patronat dans une négociation qui
s'est enclenchée après 2003 après la
réforme de 2003 mais le patronat dit
aujourd'hui c'est pas possible on peut
pas mesurer les charges lourdes que
certains P portent à genou peut les
mesurer nous avons proposé c'est que
dans le cas de la mission qui est
confiée à monsieur
devirville nous regardions comment les
choses soient pas compliquées mais sans
remettre en cause le compte pénibilité
sans remettre en cause que pour des gens
qui subissent une carrière pénible des
travaux pénibles qui vont vivre moins
longtemps ou en moins bonne santé et
bien nousous compr la justice de la
démarche bien sûr mais est-ce que vous
avezce que vous craignez que ce compte p
ibilité soit aujourd'hui en surcis en
raison des assauts du patronat et puis
des doutes formulés par le gouvernement
par la voix du ministre du travail même
si voulez pas entend parler qui a dit
que certaines mesures attendront hein du
côté du gouvernement je je je ne leur
conseille pas que ce compte pénibilité
soit en sursis et j'ai plutôt le
sentiment que ce n'est pas le cas et du
côté du patronnage je les invite plutôt
à réfléchir au fait que ce soit pas
compliqué il y a une mission avec
Monsieur de Virville sur le sujet il y
aura aussi une mission parlementaire
pour évaluer les effets travailler dans
ce cadre là j'ai envie de dire au
patronat mais par contre ce
compteibilité il se mettra en place
parce que c'est juste une mesure de
justice sociale alors on va reparler du
patronat tout à l'heure il est très
revendicatif en ce moment je vois que du
côté de la CFDT les chauffeurs routiers
ont menacé de mener des opérations coup
de point avant les fêtes pour des
questions salariales est-ce que la
menace est toujours d'actualité oui tout
simplement parce que vous savez en 2009
pardon il y avait un accord dans la dans
ce secteur là pour relever les minimas
de branche qui prévoyait que les le le
minima il soit au-dessus au-dessus du
SMIC depuis parce qu'il n'y a pas eu
renégociation ces minima ils sont en
dessous du SMIC il y a trois catégories
de salariés qui soient ouvriers ou
employés qui sont en dessous du SMIC
dans les minimas et donc ils sont
attrapés par le SMIC et il n'y a pas
possibilité d'ouvrir de réelles
négociations dans ce secteur là donc
avant les avant les fêtes c'està-dire
jeudi jeudi vendredi les routiers de la
CFDT vont dire au patronat qu'il faut
rouvrir ces négociations vont des
opérations qui viseront pas à embêter
les salariés et et les et les et les
usagers mais qui diront qui seront dire
au patronat de routier qu'il faut ouvrir
ses négociations d'accord alors il y a
des manifestations en Europe vous avez
vu on a vu cela en Belgique on a vu ça
en Italie en France il n'y a pas de
manifestation en tous les cas elle ne
mobilise pas les foules de salariés hein
ce sont les patrons qui descendent dans
la rue euh votre homologue de force
ouvriillère jean-clun Mailli a adressé
aujourd'hui un avertissement au
gouvernement il l'appelle à arrêter sa
politique d'austérité est-ce que vous
avez la même revendication non mais
arrêterz la politique d'austérité euh ça
voudrait dire qu'il y a de l'austérité
en France qui a en France il y a euh de
la rigueur mais de l'austérité c'est ce
que connaissent malheureusement nos
camarades des pays du l'Europe du Sud
euh c'est-à-dire c'est des c'est des
minimas sociaux qui baissent c'est la
baisse du salaire des fonctionnaires et
cetera aujourd'hui on a de la rigueur
qui est pas forcément toujours facile à
vivre et qui est pas forcément
acceptable parce qu'elle est pas
toujours juste mais ceci étant moi c'est
pas une revendication ça ce que je dis
moi c'est qu'en Belgique en Italie ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui c'est dans des
pays qui sont en situation difficile
c'est d'abord des réformes qui sont pas
discutées qui ne sont pas discutés avec
les organisations syndicales ni en
Belgique où le gouvernement essaie de
passer en force sans avoir même pris le
temps de discuter avec les organisations
syndicales ni en Italie où Monsieur
renzy remet en cause des dispositions du
leur code du travail sans en avoir
discuté avec les fr c'est pas le cas
donc en France il un dialogue social
encore riche avec le gouvernement
dites-v France non avec en France il y a
encore du dialogue social
il faut le mettre en place mais il faut
que l'assemble des acteurs participe
autour de la table ceci étant quand la
CFDT n'est pas d'accord avec des mesures
injustes ou quand elle est pas d'accord
avec des situations qui sont fait au
salariés on se mobilise comme on l'
faireclaude il parle d'une il y a une
condamnation générale et il envisage
d'ailleurs une grève
interprofessionnelle si possible une
action commune on a compris que ça
serait sans la
CFDT je pas monsieur enfin évidemment
que de toute façon ça se décrète pas et
puis deuxièmement moi j'ur répond pas
aux convocations des autres leaders
syndicaux euh donc la la la question je
ne sais pas de quoi vous faites
référence je crois que c'est
rassemblement le F du gouvernement dans
le dialogue social dans sa politique
économique écoutez la CFDT elle est
engagée aujourd'hui sur plusieurs
actions elle est engagé d'abord dans les
branches pour faire en sorte que dans le
cadre du cadre PCT de responsabilité on
est des embauches on est de
l'investissement on est de la formation
et l'élévation des compétences elle est
engagée dans les branches
professionnelles notamment dans les
discussions concernant les minimas
sociaux comme chez les routiers pour
faire en sorte que les choses
s'améliorent elle est engagée dans les
entreprises pour se battre pour l'emploi
pour le pouvoir d'achat pour de
meilleures conditions de travail c'est
là que l'action syndicale se passe s'il
y avait un moment besoin d'avoir des
actions plus larges nous verrions mais
c'est pas en répondre à une
interrogation de jeill d'accord mais je
note quand même que vous estimez qu'en
France il n'y a pas d'austérité et vous
savez l'austérité moi je suis attaché au
mot et à la valeur des mots ou
l'austérité c'est quand on on baisse
drastiquement et malheureusement ça
existe en Europe évid on a connu la
Grèce mais c'est au Portugal où les
fonctionnaires ont vu leur salaire
baisser entre 5 à 10 % ça a été le cas
en Italie c'est ça a été le cas en
Espagne aujourd'hui en France il y a une
politique de rigueur budgétaire on le
sait tous ça pèse sur le pouvoir d'achat
c'est pas forcément ça mais ça ne veut
pas dire ça ne veut pas dire que ça
s'appelle l'austérité ça veut pas dire
que la situation des salariés français
elle est facile pour autant mais
heureusement parce que la CFDT je vais
vous donner un exemple oui il était
prévu au 1er septembre un relèvement du
des minimas sociaux du RSA de 2 %
le gouvernement avait décidé avait
proposé au printemps de pas faire cette
revalorisation la CFDT seul s'est
mobilisé en disant il est hors de
question de pas faire cette
révalorisation nous l'avons faite ça
c'est pas une politique d'austérité
c'est de l'action syndicale utile pour
les plus fragiles d'accord alors on le
disait le MF mais aussi les autres
organisations patronnales mobilisent y
compris dans la rue c'est le cas de la
CGPME avant donc de retrouver
Jean-Philippe chogot de laafp cette
plongé dans cette contestation patronale
qui crispe les relations avec Pierre
Gatas dans tous les cas du gouver de
votre côté vous allez pouvoir nous le
dire dans un instant Sam
Deir pendant que les syndicats italiens
ou belges manifeste en France ce sont
les patrons qui descendent dans la rue
du compte pénibilité au trop plein de
taxes le front créé début décembre
rassemblait aussi bien les grands
groupes du mdeef que les petits patrons
et artisans c'est historique nous sommes
sur des entreprises à caractère
totalement différent mais lorsque nous
ne sommes plus entendus lorsque nous ne
sommes pas compris nous sommes obligés
de nous mobiliser pour essayer de faire
bouger les choses une colère des petits
patrons sur laquelle surf pierre Gatz
pour pousser son avantage le patron du
MDEF propose par exemple de supprimer la
justification obligatoire des
licenciements des pavés dans la marre de
quoi crisper le dialogue social avec les
syndicats et le gouvernement chacun doit
être à la hauteur de ses responsabilités
et je le dis notamment au dirigeants du
patronat un certain nombre de propos
de provocation de propos aujourd'hui ne
sont pas à la hauteur de cette
responsabilité après avoir annoncé 41
milliard d'euros d'aide aux entreprises
l'exécutif ne comprend pas la surenchè
de Pierre gataz il est sur une ligne de
crête dans lequel il souhaite d'une part
conforter un certain nombre d'actes de
la politique du gouvernement par exemple
les baisses de charges par exemple
travail du dimanche disposition
de la loi Macron donc de de conforter ça
de ne pas se fâcher vraiment avec le
gouvernement et d' notre côté c'est
l'autre côté de la crête éviter d'être
mis en minorité en quelque sorte par sa
base qui est très impatient très
mécontente à raison de la conjoncture
économique exiger plus pour ne pas être
débordé par sa base au risque de bloquer
le dialogue social ce serait alors le
Parlement qui reprendrait la main pour
réformer le droit du TR
voilà Jean-Philippe chot est avec nous
notre confrère du service social de la
FP bonsoir Jean-Philippe vos questions
àor berger alors on vient de voir un
sujet sur le patronat qui est très
revendicatif est-ce que c'est pour vous
encore un partenaire avec qui on peut
négocier bah de toute façon pour un
syndicaliste le patronat c'est toujours
un interlocuteur on le choisit pas quand
j'étais dans mon entreprise je
choisissais pas le le directeur avec
lequel je discutais là je discute avec
les organisations patronnales il y en a
trois aujourd'hui je le fais moi ce que
je dis au patronat c'est qu'à un moment
donné il faut arrêter la complainte puis
il faut être dans l'engagement et la
responsabilité ils ont une occasion de
le faire c'est le PACT de responsabilité
les négociations qui sont dans les
branches aujourd'hui il y en a six qui
ont qui ont conclu à des accords avec
des embauches avec de l'investissement
avec de de la formation professionnelle
avec de l'apprentissage il y en a pas
assez donc moi je dis dans la grande
distribution dans la l'hospitalisation
privée dans la transformation
agroalimentaire et puis plein d'autres
encore il faut maintenant s'engager et
arrêter de se plaindre le gouvernement
avait justement parlé d'échec parce
qu'il y avait pas assez d'accord est-ce
que on est toujours en échec non mais le
PCT de responsabilité pleinement il
prend sa son son envol d'une certaine
manière au au 1er janvier c'est là où on
revient sur les retraite c'estàdire que
on est quand même dans un pays un peu
bizarre c'est il y a pas d'échec il y a
aujourd'hui le pied sur le frein de la
part du patronat dans un certain nombre
de branches donc il a encore je l'ai
déjà dit plusieurs fois il a encore
quelques mois quelques semaines pour
négocier les accords dans les branches
et puis après ce sera le Parlement qui
prendra ses responsabilités la CFDT
appellera les parlementaires à prendre
leur responsabilités nous ferons le
bilan de nombre d'accords dans les
branches de ce qu'ils auront produit en
terme de contenu évidemment ça mettra du
temps à se mettre en œuvre la politique
économique ça se décrète pas ça se
construit et puis en fonction de
l'engagement ou pas de la responsabilité
assumée ou pas du patronat ben les
parlementaires décideront si pour 2016
ils accordent des aides supplémentaires
prévu dans la trajectoire ou si ils
disent ils font le constat que le
patronat n'a pas assumé sa
responsabilité c'est ça pour la CFDT qui
est sur la table aujourd'hui ce ne sont
pas les complaintes du patronat
Fustel manifesté par des manifestations
de rue sur lequel nous avons envie de
nous arrêter nous avons envie de lui
dire mettez prenez vos responsabilités
mais vous laissez apparemment quelques
semaines donc d'ici début de l'année
prochaine pour pour s'engager encore
mais le patronat déjà eu 6 milliards
d'euros dans le cadre du PACT dans le
cadre du cice qui inclus dans le PCT le
cice c'est par par entreprise là il est
prévu dans les entreprises qui qu'il y
ait des négociations enfin des
informations au comité entreprise il y
en a très peu qui l'ont fait en gros
un/ers c'était le première année de mise
en œuvre de du CCE donc là nous avons
souhaité que pour l'année prochaine
notamment l'ensemble des comités
entreprises soit informé sur
l'utilisation de ces sommes mais ce qui
est prévu dans les négociations de
branche c'est bien ce qui les les
allaigements les aides aux entreprises
qui seront octroyé à compté du 1er
janvier donc il faut qu'il s'engage
c'est tout et moi je ne serai pas dans
ceux qui diront il y a un échec ou pas
un échec aujourd'hui mais par contre je
peux vous assurer qu'en mars avril je je
saurais dire combien d'emplois sont
prévus dans les branches combien de
jeunes en apprentissage et est-ce que le
patronat a oui ou non assumé ses
responsabilités et pour l'instant c'est
bien parti bah pour l'instant c'est 6
sur 50 grandes branches don enfin c'est
C grand CQ grandes branches sur 6 50
branches de de sur lesquelles était
ciblé c'est pas suffisant donc nous nous
avavons de cess et dans les branches nos
équipes de de de de de de de mettre sous
pression le patronat pour qu'il négocie
et de cesse de dire au gouvernement
qu'il faut qu'il soit plus exigeant à
l'gard du patronat vous voulez que le
gouvernement lui également exerce des
pressions mais on a l'impression que les
relation les engagements des uns et des
autres vous savez le PCT de
responsabilité c'est quoi c'est à un
moment donné une politique de l'offre
qui peut être intelligente en disant il
faut investir dans un autre mode de
production dans notre pays en faisant
davantage d'investissement notamment li
à la transition écologique en formant
davantage les salariés en recrutant des
jeunes et en faisant de l'emploi et on
sait tous que l'emploi
cade coup ça non c'est pas je vais
revenir et l'emploi on c'est tout ce qui
vient l'investissement des cadeau au
patronat pourquoi parce que ça serait
considérer qu'une entreprise c'est un
patron une entreprise ce sont aussi des
salariés et une entreprise c'est ce que
j'appelle moi une propriété sociale et
donc faire des aides aux entreprises
c'est faire en sorte que l'emploi
l'investissement s'y développe mais pour
ça il faut que le patronat s'y engage
comprenne que c'est ça l'enjeu et si il
ne le comprend pas malheureusement ça
voudra dire que c'est un échec pour lui
parce que en faisant ce qu'il fait
aujourd'hui le patronat il joue contre
son camp il joue contre le camp des
entreprises donc il faut qu'il s'engage
plus je dois le dire que ces dernières
semaines il y a eu des des accords
importants il y en a eu dans les
assurances euh et c'est une bonne chose
il y en a eu dans la chimie il y en a
dans la métallurgie dans la propreté ça
se discute euh en ce moment mais ça
progresse il y a d'autres secteurs où ça
progresse vous êtes optimiste mais
mobilisé je je suis mobilisé parce que
le rôle d'un syndicaliste c'est d'être
mobilisé pour faire avancer l'emploi et
la situation des salariés et il y a un
autre sujet sur lequel vous êtes
confronté au patron c'est la négociation
en ce moment sur le dialogue social dans
l'entreprise on a l'impression que c'est
en point mort que la prochaine séance a
été reportée de jeudi au mois suivant
est-ce que vous n'avez pas l'impression
que le patronat une partie du patronat
essaie de faire capoter le la
négociation parce qu'il espère avoir
plus si c'est le gouvernement qui
reprend la main ça serait un très
mauvais calcul je pense que si le
patronat reprend la main par une loi qui
serait portée par le ministre du Travail
euh je pense que c'est un très mauvais
calcul sur le cœur de ce que sont les
relations sociales c'estàdire un
dialogue social entreprise de faire
faire confiance au patron au
gouvernement de la part du patronat ceci
étant je je je pense que le report de
cette discussion qui avait aussi des
problèmes de calendrier pour la fin de
la semaine il doit permettre quoi il
doit permettre d'avancer sur la
représentation de tous les salariés y
compris ceux des toutes petites
entreprises il doit permettre d'avancer
sujet sur lequel le patronat n'a jamais
encore fait de pas sujet sur lequel le
patronat il a peut-être besoin d'un peu
de temps supplémentaire pour en discuter
bah qu' l'utilise à bon essant euh il y
a besoin d'avancer sur le la
reconnaissance des parcours des des des
militants sur la qualité du dialogue
social notamment sur le fait que on
puisse avoir un dialogue social en terme
d'information consultation c'est un peu
technique mais c'est quand même le cœur
du réacteur soit plus simple donc il il
y a un certain nombre de sujets qui sont
sur la table aujourd'hui nous allons y
travailler ça veut pas dire que parce
que la séance est programmé début
janvier qu'entreemp personne TR ce soit
sur le PACT ou sur cette négociation
est-ce que vous jouez pas gros parce que
sur le PACT vous êtes engagé vous l'avez
dit dans la première partie sur la
négociation enfin c'est c'est un peu
est-ce que c'est pas un peu l'avenir du
dialogue og social qui se joue ah mais
je suis persuadé que nous sommes à un
moment charnière à un moment charnière
et le patronat il va falloir qu'il
décide entre est-ce qu'on fait le choix
du dialogue social pour avancer dans
notre pays sur la situation économique
sociale ou est-ce que on reste chacun
dans son camp et vous savez c'est pas la
CFDT qui peut être accusé à un moment
donné de pas s'engager dans le dialogue
social moi je crois que pour ça il faut
être au moins deux et bien c'est au
patronat de démontrer qu'il est prêt à
le faire et de de de considérer il faut
qu'il considère que le dialogue social
c'est un outil de performance économique
et sociale c'est pas un pour les
entreprises loin sans faux alors il y a
d'autres sujets dans sur la table he qui
font débat alors la loi Macron la loi
Macron notamment avec parmi ces très
nombreux volets le travail du dimanche
12 dimanche c'est une régression sociale
comm 12 dimanche c'est beaucoup trop
d'abord 12 dimanche c'est un espèce
d'épouvantail il y en avait CIN
aujourd'hui on sait bien que les cinq
étaient pas utilisés dans les dans les
zones dans les zones touristiques ou
dans les zone définie commerciale
définie comme pouvant ouvrir donc bien
sûr que c'est trop ça ça c'est au
parlementaires de le
dire moi avant je dis C je dis 5 je suis
un syndicaliste 5 aujourd'hui je dis 5
c'est un syndicaliste mais au-delà de ça
audelà de ça non moi je suis pour que le
travail du dimanche soit une exception
ce soit pas banalisé ce soit pas
généralisé et lorsqu'il y a une
justification économique dans des zones
que le législateur va définir il faut
que la condition sineéquanon c'est qu'il
y ait compensation pour les salariés qui
soit non non c'est pas prévu pour les
moins de 20 qui soit des compensations
pour les salar qui soit fixé par accord
uniquement c'est-à-dire pour dire les
choses autrement dans les zones en
question il y a accord qui fixe les
contreparties les compensations pour les
salariés pour l'ensemble des salariés
quel que soit la taille des entreprise
où il n'y a pas ouverture de dimanche
voilà une bonne voie si le gouvernement
nous entend sur ce pointlà et bien nous
prendrons nos responsabilités pour voir
en fonction de l'intérêt des salariés
s'il y a ouverture ou pas et là pour
vous justement pour les la compensation
salariale quel est votre minimum ce qui
se pratique aujourd'hui on le sait dans
les entreprises dans un certain nombre
de branches c'est 100 % du Sala salaire
multiplié par 2 en fait c'est ce qui se
pratique le ministre de l'Économie
Emmanuel Macron a dit que ça pourrait
pas être tenable de écoutez puisque
puisque on dit que c'est confié à la
négociation et ben laissons les
négociateurs faire lorsqu'ils seront
soumis à cette question et vous avez une
deuxième une deuxième condition pour le
travail du dimanche c'est le volontariat
est-ce que c'est pas un peu utopique par
exemple si un candidat arrive en
entretien d' B et dit moi je veux pas
travailler le dimanche comment on peut
faire en sorte que le recruteur ne
nécarte pas n'écarte pas d'office sa sa
sa candidature cette condition elle est
très importante mais elle est pas
utopique je vais vous dire pourquoi ce
que vous dites est une réalité
évidemment le la personne qui va arriver
en disant je veux pas travailler le
dimanche c'est compliqué mais on a on a
des accords d'entreprise vous savez il
faut faire parler l'intelligence des
acteurs au plus près et on a un accord
par exemple à la FNAC au knit à la
défense qui prévoit que cette clause de
volontariat elle soit revu tous les 6
mois alors évidemment qu'une personne
qui sera embauchée les 6 premiers mois
elle aura des difficultés pour dire non
mais ensuite puisque c'est le bontariat
vérifié par les représentants du
personnel et que il y a une y a une
possibilité de remise en cause on peut
aller sur ce volontarat vous savez faut
pas considérer que tout doit être fixé
par la loi moi je crois beaucoup et
notre démocratie souffre de ça au marge
de manœuvre au plus près d'où sont les
gens à condition que ce soit encadré et
là l'accord en question et ben il permet
de revenir sur le volontariat lorsque le
salarié pour des raisons personnelles
n'a plus le soit de travailler le
dimanche si vous étiez député donc on a
compris vous ne voteriez pas la loi
Macron non mais je suis pas député je
pense ah non non mais je je me place
jamais dans cette
situationl imaginons vousz voter vous
vous vous voteriez non ah mais vous
savez dans la loi Macron j'ai dit que
c'était un patchwork un peu difficile à
lire d'accord mais il faut voter oui ou
non alors et ben justement je ne suis
pas député moi je suis représentant des
salariés et comme je suis représentant
des salariés je dis qu'il y a des points
sur lesquels nous sommes d'accord dans
cette loi euh c'est notamment une partie
de la réforme des prudomes qui
permettront de de rendre une justice
plus rapide euh plus sécure pour les
salariés je suis d'accord avec des
choses qui qui concernent l'inspection
du travail parce que ça permettra
d'avoir un pouvoir réglementaire plus
important de l'inspection du travail à
gar entreprises puis il y a des choses
avec lesquelles je suis en interrogation
et en demande parce que c'est mon boulot
d'obtenir des avancé sur le travail du
dimanche ou des choses avec lesquelles
sur notamment l'ordre des licenciement
je suis en désaccord et nous essayons
d'influer vous savez moi mon travail
c'est pas de voter ou pas les lois c'est
de dire pour les représentants pour les
salariés ce qui me semble bon ou pas bon
et d'infléchir cette loi lorsqu'elle me
paraît mais justement sur le travail du
sur le principe vous nêtes pas
totalement opposé du moment que c'est
sur la base du volontariat avec une
compensation est-ce que et à partir du
moment où c'est pas généralisé vous
savez je suis pas sûr qu'on est pas en
train de se faire un débat qui soit
assez parisien parisien parce que moi là
d'où je viens c'est-à-dire saint-nazer
en Loire Atlantique la question d'ouvrir
12 dimanchees mais il y a aucun intérêt
à faireansout Rais c'est peuttre
une aucun intérêt à le faire et et les C
qui sont pas utilisés je vous le disais
donc je crois que il faut surtout faire
en sorte qu'on ait des règles claires et
le meilleur moyen dans les avoir c'est
il y a des zones défines et ensuite
c'est la négociation collective entre
les représentants des salariés et les
représentants des entreprises qui
permettra de fixer les conditions
d'ouverture ou pas voilà quelque chose
de simple vous défendez l'emploi qui se
porte si mal dans notre pays les grands
magasins du Boulevard Osmane dans la
capital disent si on peut ouvrir le
dimanche il y aura des milliers
d'embauches c'est un argument auquel
vous êtes sensible ou vous d'abord il fa
il faudrait le il faut vérifier les
arguments économiques vous savez nous on
nous a dit à un moment donné il
suffirait de revoir les seuils et puis
il y aurait 150 ou 200000 emplois et
puis toutes les études qui qui
paraissent depuis nous disent que c'est
pas le cas attendez soyons soyons
pragmatiques hein soyons clair si il y a
un intérêt économique ça ne peut se
faire que si il y a de vraies
compensations pour les salariés pour
l'instant c'est à eux aussi de le
définir par des négociations c'est ce
qu'on a proposé dernière question oui
est-ce que le fait de ne pas être
totalement de ne pas totalement fermer
la porte justement au travail du
dimanche est-ce que ça vous met pas un
peu en porte à faux par rapport à
certains une partie de votre base
notamment on a vu des drapeaux de la
CFDT dans la manifestation aujourd'hui à
Paris mais ça nous met pas du tout en
non nous sommes tout à fait totalement
en accord c'était c'est notre base comme
vous dites n no nos délégués avec
lesquel nous discutons en continu ils
disent nous voulons des compensations et
nous voulons pas les ouvertures
simplement pour des ouvertures et nous
voulons que ce soit cadré donc c'est
c'est complètement en cohérence je je je
le dis je pense qu'il faut arrêter de
d'avoir une vision de ces choseslà le
travail du dimanche le dimanche c'est un
jour qui doit être chôé y compris pour
des questions sociétales il peut avoir
des exceptions ça ne peut être que des
exception et ces exceptions elles doit
être bénéfique pour les salariés si
jamais elles existent très bien voilà
qui est clair merci Jean-Philippe c'est
vrai que votre base en ce moment la CFDT
est quand même moins secoué que celle de
la CGT n'est-ce pas perinna depu Sénat
arrive maintenant le climat est vraiment
mauvais pour l'ensemble des syndicats
néanmoins en raison de l'affaire Thierry
Lepan à la CGT c'est ce qu'on voit tout
de suite avec Jérôme Rabier
pour moi je pense qu'il faut un
changement de
secrétaire a un discrédite au niveau du
secrétaire à la CGT comme ailleurs il
doit y avoir peut-être un grand balayage
et puis peut-être un peu plus de
démocratie la CGT s'enlise dans
l'affaire le pan et tous les voyants
passent au rouge pour la centrale de
monreuil résultat en baisse dans les
élections professionnelles de la semaine
dernière et plus grave seulement 31 %
des Français ont une bonne opinion de ce
syndicat une chute de 14 points en à
peine 2 ans éosion cible de la côte de
la CGT auprès de l'ensemble des Français
comme auprès des
salariés cette érosion est sans doute
très lié et indexé sur l'affaire ou les
affaires le pan si les autres centrales
ont pu profiter de la baisse de la CGT
dans ses bastion pas question pour
autant de l'accabler car c'est
l'ensemble du mouvement syndical qui est
en danger les critiques portées en
direction de Thierry Lepan secrétaire
général la CGT rejaillissent ses
critiques sur l'ensemble du mouvement
syndical aliment d'une certaine certaine
façon l'idée que le syndicalisme comme
les partis politiques sont dirigés par
des personnes qui ont la main dans le
pot de confiture avant même que un autre
syndicat puisse tirer les marrons du feu
c'est l'ensemble de la sphère syndicale
qui est impacté c'est la confiance
générale dans les syndicats une
interrogation sur leur utilité qui va
gagner du terrain et qui va se traduire
par une abstention qui progressera une
abstention qui a atteint des records
cette année preuve que la vitalité
syndicale est en danger mais plus que
sur cette affaire le pan c'est désormais
la ligne politique de la CGT qui doit
être tranchée si elle veut rebondir
aujourd'hui comme ailleurs en Europe les
autres syndicats français évoluent ou
sont déjà depuis longtemps campés dans
un syndicalisme qui privilégie la
négociation et là la CGT ne s'est pas
prononcé n'a pas eu son débat interne
sur le type de syndicalisme qu'il faut
adopter pour être de son temps alors que
la CGT signe 85 % des accords dans les
entreprises elle n'a pas signé un accord
national depuis l'élection de François
Hollande face à un gouvernement qui
s'assume réformiste mieux vaut afficher
la même volonté la CFDT qui a fait ce
choix il y a quelques années peut rêver
de bientôt détrôner la CGT qui
vailà est ave
nousons vos questions secrtaire général
de la CFDT alors je vous rassure on va
pas faire le procès de la CGT je pense
que vous ne l'accepteriez pas mais quand
même ce soir thier le nexclut plus de
démissionner est-ce que ça serait la
bonne décision c'est pas à moi de me
prononcer là-dessus depuis le début j'ai
une ligne de conduite elle est double
elle est d'abord de dire que les
histoires de la CGT ça concerne la CGT
pas seulement on l'a vu le deuxième
ligne de conduite ah c'est qu'il ne faut
pas faire d'amalgame il ne faut pas
faire d'amalgame que ça c'est pas trop
tard non c'est pas trop tard parce que
moi je suis désolé il faut pas il faut
pas laisser penser que l'ensemble des
syndicalistes qu'il so quel qu'il soit
d'ailleurs y compris évidemment les
militants de terrain de la CGT qui font
du travail
au quotidien serait concerné par par par
par des dérives et donc je je le dis
avec force ce soir j'en ai un peu assez
de laisser penser que parce que il y a
un sujet d'un secrétaire général de la
CGT l'ensemble du syndicalisme sera
impacté l'ensemble du syndicalisme en
souffre je suis d'accord mais euh je
veux bien sont quand même un peu touché
par cette affaire fin par rejaillir bah
ça finit par rejaillir et on laisse à
penser éedito après éedito dans certains
dans certaines presses que en fait ça
serait l'ensemble du syndicalisme qui
sera impacté m dans
lesitureortage oui c'est c'est terrible
et votre reportage montre deux choses
c'est d'abord sur la ligne politique je
crois pas que la CFDT elle a beaucoup de
démonstrations à faire qu'elle a une
ligne politique et qu'elle l'assume et
puis d'autre part sur l'éthique
personnel des des des dirigeants de la
CFDT il y a pas beaucoup de choses à
dire non plus donc je veux le dire je
veux le dire il faut arrêter avec ça
après sur ce qui concerne la CGT je n'ai
rien à dire et j'ai pas de commentaire à
faire c'est dommage parce que
là il est poussé à la démission par
beaucoup de fédérations professionnelles
de la CGT vous n'avez pas envie de dire
la même chose plutôt qu'il évite une
humiliation celle de la révocation mais
c'est pas mon problème moi vous savez je
suis pas du tout poussé à la démission
par les troubles de la CFDT donc c'est
ça qui me
préoccupe bien sûr et donc et ben que
Monsieur que que la CGT s'occupe de ses
affaires vous quand vous êtes passé de
saintager à Paris vous n'avez pas touché
de prime he nont
ouais est-ce que vous estimez qu'à
travers les on vient d'entendre les
sonurs dans dans ce reportage que
finalement le syndicalisme aujourd'hui
est victime de la même défiance que les
politiques mais je crois que le
syndicalisme les politique le patronat
les médias encore plus dans les enquêtes
d'opinion sont soumis à la défance des
citoyens et que et que et que à le
nourrir les uns et les autres on se fait
beaucoup de mal à notre démocratie et
donc je pense que quand il y a des
dérives il faut qu'elles soit euh euh
Poé mais je pense que quand il y a de la
noblesse de l'engagement et notamment de
l'engagement syndical comme de
l'engagement politique ou de de de
l'entrepreneuriat par exemple pour par
des entreprises et bien il faut aussi
qu'on le souligne notre démocratie
elle peut souffrir du tous pourri et on
sait on sait bien que le tous pourri il
nous emmène vers la dérive des extrêmes
et donc nos citoyens les citoyens mais
vous savez les salariés en ce moment il
faut confiance à la CFDT dans les
entreprises le taux de participation aux
élections professionnel dans le privé et
même dans le public où il y a une légère
baisse il est assez fort il est plus
fort que dans bien nombre d'élections
politiques et je m'en réjouis pas parce
que moi je suis un démocrate et je
souhaiterais que les citoyens votent for
que dans d'autres pays européens le le
tau de partici participation aux
élections professionnelles il est très
très fort dans notre pays et il
aujourd'hui il démontre que la CFDT a
recueille la confiance des salariés
c'est la CGT là qui vous aide à
remporter des victoires comme Orange non
je crois que c'est l'action de nos
militants c'est l'action de nos
militants vous savez depuis orange on a
connu une situation dramatique vous vous
vous en rappelez et la CFDT elle a fait
le choix du dialogue social en disant ça
doit cesser et pour ça il faut un
dialogue social et puisqu'il y a eu du
dialogue social il y a eu des avancées
les gens étaient reconnus ils ont
reconnu l'organisation syndicale qui
avait fait ce travail là pareil à La
Poste à la Poste nous avons signé un
accord sur le courrier dont on sait
qu'il est malheureusement menacé parce
que et vous et moi nous envoyons moins
de courrier cet accord il a pas pu
s'appliquer avant les élections
professionnelles parce qu'il recueillait
pas 30 %. la CFDT a assumé la signature
de cet accord même s'il entait pas en
application la CFDT a recueilli
d'excellents résultats à la poste parce
que notre syndicalisme d'engagement il
recueille de l'adhésion de la pase P que
ce syndicalisme là de négociation va
suffire à repousser les extrêmes comme
vous venez le dire vous avez dit que le
danger en ce moment sont les extrêmes je
crois que face à la démagogie face au
populisme face au simplisme on doit
parler aux gens partant de la réalité
mais leur apporter de l'espoir et des
solutions le rôle du syndicalisme c'est
d'apporter des propositions et des
solutions et de s'engager pour qu'elles
aboutissent la CFDT toute seule vous
savez je ne suis pas toute seule elle y
arrivera pas mais en tout cas elle tient
sa part de responsabilité et nous
l'assumons et donc moi je ne veux pas
avoir à me justifier sur tel ou telle
dérive ou tel ou tel manquement du
syndicalisme quand l'organisation que je
dirige assume sa part de responsabilité
dans un syndicalisme constructif de
proposition et de résultats pour les
salari malgré la période difficile ouais
mais auudelà de laaffire le pan on voit
bien qu'il y a une porosité de plus en
plus grande entre certains syndicat
entre des adhérents que ça soit la CFDT
la CGT Force ouvrière et autres et le
Front national comment le conter comment
essayer d'enrayer cette porosité d'abord
il y a deux il y a deux niveaux bien
d'abord je l'ai dit je viens de le dire
le terrain de la proposition de
l'explication de la réalité telle
qu'elle est et pas et puis il y a le
terrain des valeurs vous savez je crois
que notre démocratie elle a un choix là
en ce moment à faire elle a le choix
entre plus de coopération plus de
dialogue plus de de capacité des
organisations à transcender leur leur
propre sujet pour essayer de trouver les
voies du progrès collectif du destin un
collectif où il y a une voix très
autoritaire du rejet de l'autre du Bou
émissaire du simplisme qui nous emmène
finalement dans le mur ben moi je fais
le choix de la coopération de la
démocratie du dialogue c'est plus
exigeant c'est plus exigeant c'est
tellement c'est tellement facile parler
de l'austérité tout à l'heure cel la
donne renvoie peut-être une image
d'austérité de votre pe de vousême de
votre vous vous connaissez des
démocraties qui sont construits
autrement que par leur capacité à faire
se confronter des intérêts
contradictoires pour faire émerger des
compromis je n'en connais aucune toute
les tous les pays qu' qui ont été tentés
de faire gagner un camp sur un autre ça
ça ça ça s'est appelé des pays
totalitair ou des dictatures et moi je
ne veux pas vivre dans un pays de ce
type donc ça veut dire qu'il faut
davantage de coopération de dialogue et
de de confrontation positive des
intérêts mais pas d'affrontement et de
recherche du B sur l'image de de la CFDT
notamment ça renvoie peut-être celle
d'un syndicat un peu moins de de
militant mais mais d'experts des
négociations sociale on en a beaucoup
parlé depuis le début de cette émission
mais écoutez je vous invite je vous
invite le 1er mai prochain un
rassemblement de jeunes de 5000 jeunes à
Paris àincep mené par la CFDT qui sera
un rassemblement qui fêtera le travail à
la manière des des jeunes à la manière
de la CFDT et qui sera pas du tout
hoster donc si vous voulez je vous y
invite ça sera un large forum ce seront
des débats ce seront des moments festifs
ce seront des rapports avec le sport et
parce que le syndicalisme c'est pas
austère contrairement la CFDT elle est
pas austère vous pouviez venir à notre
conrès elle est extrêmement conviviale
mais seulement elle est mobilisée parce
que la période est dure pour les
salariés elle ne elle ne elle ne
n'accepte cette période ni la facilité
ni le renoncement donc oui la CFDT à est
mobiliser c'est pas Auster c'est
simplement elle fait son travail ça sera
l'immersion de Michel grossur dans le
monde syndical on parla et sportif on
parlait de on parlait de de dérivve
Patrick cron va toucher une prime
exceptionnelle de 4 million d'euros pour
avoir bien conduit la vente de 70 %
dalstom euh alors qu'il a dirigé cette
entreprise à général électrique alors
même que cette vente devrait conduire
sans doute à plusieurs suppressions
centaines de suppressions d'emploi à
Belfort est-ce que cette prime selon
vous est indécente oui indécente
choquante oui je crois que vous savez
j'en ai un peu assez de de ces personnes
qui sont sans doute pleines de talent
mais qui expliquent parce qu'elles ont
fait quelque chose de bien qu'elles
peuvent avoir des primes ou des
rémunérations qui qui dépassent tout
entendement pour n'importe quel citoyen
ou salarié de ce pays donc oui je trouve
ça
indécent et je voilà je pense qu'il
faudrait pouvoir empêcher ce type de de
pratique et franchement avec ce qu'on
vient de discuter là ça montre que un
peu il y il y en a aussi dans le monde
patronal qui parfois abusent et donc là
je trouve ça choquant une position forte
de pierre gataz sur ce sujet j'espère
qu'il intervienne bah je je je pense que
c'est le rôle des leaders syndicaux ou
patronau d'intervenir dans ce pour dire
au moins ce qu'ils en pensent mais vous
savez moi j'attends pas tempant des
commentaires des uns et des autres
j'attends de la mobilisation franchement
de la mobilisation notre pays est en
difficulté elle traverse il traverse une
crise économique une crise sociale une
crise démocratique ça veut dire qu'ilut
qu'on se relève tous les manches et
qu'on arrête ce style de pratique
d'accord est-ce qu'il faut également se
détourner des recettes du passé c'est ce
qu'a dit récemment manuel valalls qui
est engagé dans un programme de réforme
on en a parlé au cours de cette émission
bien sûr le PCT de responsabilité est-ce
que vous adhérez à cette
idéelà mais je sais pas franchement ce
que c'est les recettes du passé vous
savez c'est se positionner sur ce style
de de de phrase c'est extrêmement
compliqué moi je ce que je sais c'est
que nous ne vivons pas une crise
finalement nous vivons de profonde
mutation et que ces mutations nous les
avons pas anticipé comme nous les avons
pas anticipé on les prend en pleine
figure moi ce que je crois qu'il faut se
tourner vers l'avenir l'avenir au niveau
économique vous c'est vous les syndicats
les politiques également c'est tout le
monde tout le monde on a on a attendu on
s'est pensé enfin je pense
qu'honnêtement à un moment donné on a
essayé de de on essae on a essayé de
revenir à un monde qui n'existait déjà
plus quoi et donc pour pass pour pas
faire ça il faut se dire qu'en terme de
transition économique mais aussi de
transition écologique en terme
d'évolution de modèle social pour pas
faire moins et pour faire mieux euh de
notre puissance publique la façon de
organiser puissance publique on peut
poser les choses sur la table nous les
débats c'est tout à fait sain de les
poser après il faut les trancher par le
biais du dialogue d'accord est-ce que
vous pensez que il y aura une inversion
de la courbe du chômage avant 2017 cette
expression m'a toujours hérissé parce
que moi je pense qu'il faut euh la
baisse du nombre de chômeurs parce que
le chômage c'est d'abord une réalité
sociale vécu durement par ceux qu'il
subissent et donc la CFDT comme d'autres
est mobilisé pour que le chômage baisse
il y a le PACT de responsabilité il y a
le soutien aux chômeurs il y a les
emplois aidés il y a la garantie jeune
que la CFDT a obtenu et bien tout ça il
faut que ça se mette en place j'espère
que il y aura moins de chômeurs d'ici
quelques temps et j'espère surtout qu'
on retournera un jour vers le plein
emploi très bien merci beaucoup monsieur
berger d'avoir été avec nous aujourd'hui
merci pine on va se retrouver maintenant
début 2015 n'est-ce pas pour un prochain
ex rendez-vous de preuv par TR et
d'ailleurs ce sera avec Harlem desir ce
sera le 6 janvier merci merci encore
pass bonne fête merci vous aussi on
souhaite d'excellentes fêtes à tous les
salariés merci à tous et T les citoyens
tous les citoyens et à
bientôt